So we're going to switch to ADCs and myeloma. And I stole this slide from Amrita from a discussion
we had last night, really looking at the recent advancements in immunotherapy and myeloma in the
timeline. And you can see it's a crowded space. And so a BCMA ADC, so if it's where, like where
should we be putting this drug? I will point to the left side of the slide and say that
belantamab was our first approved BCMA therapy in myeloma in 2020, right? And so we had actually
a lot of patients on belantamab back in the day, and now it's kind of fallen off the spectrum. But
let me see if I can actually bring it back in a little bit. Now, so I was thinking about this
last night and, you know, what is my algorithm? What's my BCMA algorithm? What should an algorithm
be for any one of the centers? And so the premise of the algorithm in my mind,
and this is, you know, the world according to Tom Martin, that you hopefully at UCSF,
my colleagues agree, but everyone should get a BCMA treatment. There's no doubt about it. These
are the most potent drugs. But for me, the default order is, can they get a CAR? If not, can they get
a bispecific? If not, then can they get belantamab? And that's my default order. So if it's somebody
that's BCMA exposed and it's a no, the first thing, the first question to that patient is,
can you do a CAR?
Can you put together all the, you know, what you need together? Can you put together a caregiver?
Can you get to the center? Can you stay in San Francisco for a month? And if so,
that person's a CAR candidate and we're going to proceed to CAR right away. If not, then the next
discussion is, are they a bispecific candidate? They still need a caregiver and they still need
to be able to do a lot of the driving into the academic center at the current time. Hopefully
that'll get better. And if they can't do that, then I think for sure, then we have to consider
the next, you know, therapy for them. Now over to the right side of the slide, I do think that in
fact, some of these therapies are, have patients that overlap. Some patients can do a CAR, some
patients can do a bispecific and the same patient can potentially do a BCMA. So then you have to
make a choice. But I also think there's people that there are CAR candidates that they can do
CAR and they should get CAR, but there are many people that can't and they'll never get a CAR.
And so you shouldn't even be thinking about that. So I think that's a good idea.
So then you think, is it bispecific or is it ADC? And there's other patients that, you know,
maybe they can get a BCMA bispecific and sure, you're going to give them a bispecific, but there's
also people that in fact, can't do that for many reasons, including where, you know, where they
live. Some people, I was on a call with Doug Sporoff yesterday and he's like, when I have
somebody way out in Montana, how am I going to give them these therapies? You can always give
it. So what do I think in the bottom? Bella candidates, older, maybe they have less access
to the academic center. This is really important that there's infrequent dosing. They may need to
come and get a dose every three or four months, which, which would be great actually. What we
really need to see if Bella will come back into mainstream is we need data on Bella after CAR
and bispecific. Does it, do patients respond after they've received another BCMA bispecific?
And that's really, I think quite important. All right. Now I'm going to give in the next three
minutes, some of the, of the obligatory slides on responses, et cetera. Okay. Here we go.
You guys know, Belantamab is an ADC. It works by many mechanisms, but blocks BCMA. It also,
you know, basically gets internalized releases into the, into the cell and then causes apoptosis
of the cell. And there may actually be some ADCC with this molecule. Single agent activity
was about 30% in the DREAM-2 that led to the initial FDA approval. The interesting thing,
the FDA made GSK do a dose finding phase two trial, right? So it was 2.5 versus 3.4. And lo and behold,
there was no difference. So why not go with the less toxic, less toxic dose of 2.5 with less
thrombocytopenia. And so that was brought forward. Now, as you know, the first phase three trial
failed, right? And so that was brought forward. Now, as you know, the first phase three trial
so it was taken off the market. One of the problems with Belantamab is it does cause a
keratitis. I'm not going to say more about that because somebody on the panel is going to talk
all about keratitis, but there's a bunch of DREAM studies and I have targeted Belantamab as the
comeback kid in myeloma because of the DREAM-7 and the DREAM-8 studies. Now I'll just briefly
mention DREAM-8 because somebody else is talking about Belapombex here. So the DREAM-8 study was
done with Belapombex versus Belapombex. So it's kind of Bela versus Bortezomib as a head-to-head.
And surprisingly, Bela won quite dramatically. And in fact, the PFS is probably going to be in
the order of three plus years. For those of you that don't do myeloma in the audience,
in the relapse refractory, one to three prior lines of therapy are top of the heap prior to
CARS and bispecifics, prior to the data that you've seen over the last day or two.
It has been ESA-KD and DERA-KD with 30 to 36 months PFS. This may eclipse it. This may actually
be the top of the heap. And that's really pretty amazing for Belantamab, right? The medium PFS,
obviously, in the control arm was a lot less. What about DREAM-7? DREAM-7 was head-to-head
Belantamab versus DERA-tubemab. So it's BelaVD versus DERA-VD. And this was a standard relapse
population. About a quarter of the patients had high-risk cytogenetics. And here we go,
median PFS, 36 months versus 13 months. Bela crushed DERA-tubemab in a head-to-head,
that's, you know, in combinations. That's amazing actually, right? And so this was approved by the
FDA. I will point out that, you know, in the LEN, also in the LEN refractory, in the high-risk
cytogenetics, this performed quite well. It's actually a very good combination. And there was
a trend favoring BelaVD versus DERA-VD in overall survival. And that's really what led the FDA to
approve this combination. Why the FDA didn't approve DERA-pomdex, we'll never know. If you
listened to the ODAC meeting, you might know in the back of your mind. But not that it was bias or
anything. I'm just saying, if you listened, you would have been okay. The one point I'm going to
point is, Bela does induce some keratopathy, and then you have to lengthen out the dosing.
And the dosing can go to every three months, can go to every four months. I used to do it back in
the day, on-demand Bela. Somebody's light chains would go to 300, I'd give them a dose of Bela that
goes back down to 50. I'd say, come back in three months, let's see. Three months, it's 50, I say,
okay, come back three more months. And they get a dose every, twice a year, that was it.
And I have some 80-year-olds that keep asking me, is that drug, that Bela drug, is that coming back
out? Because I like that one. I only got a couple of doses a year. All right. The last thing I'll
say is, at ASH, look at ASH 2025, Mari V. Mateos actually presented data on first relapse and
functional high risk. And where the arrow is on the right, I want you to look at that. One prior
line of therapy, DOR was 36 months for one line prior therapy and one prior line of therapy,
functional high risk, 32 months. Those are really, really high risk.
Really impressive data. And with that, I'll end and pass the baton.